taped five episodes
and i went home so miserable so
depressed because i said for the first
time i've done five hours of television
and i did nothing
because
as a comedian when you're doing
something you're not getting laughs well
it wasn't funny yeah i wasn't doing line
lines uh like that were given to me from
a script i was it was the first time i
was just howie and i was just doing
nothing i got a call on the morning
after it aired the first time rob smith
called me and he goes you're not gonna
believe this it went through the roof
and i went what he goes the ratings are
unprecedented i go for what he goes our
show it aired and rob called me and said
it's even bigger on the second night and
it was bigger on the third night and
that at the end of the week
100 million people had watched it on
goosebumps on the network
goosebumps 100 million people i got on a
plane i came back i landed in miami
within 30 seconds of landing the first
person that made eye contact with me
went deal or no deal goosebumps man that
could be a rat